and 2045 there's nowhere left to go
nowhere except the oasis
[Music]
I was born in 2025 but I wish I'd grown
up in the 1980s like all my heroes I
live here in Columbus Ohio and 2045 that
still ranked the fastest growing city on
earth
but sure doesn't seem like it when you
live in the stacks they called our
generation the missing millions missing
not because we went anywhere there's
nowhere left to go nowhere except the
Oasis
the only place that feels like I mean it
a world where the limits of reality or
your own imagination
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
today some for me
[Music]
[Applause]
when he's gone
[Music]
[Music]
we're going to do this let's engage
[Music]
[Music]
okay
nothing's you can go back to the women
invoice
[Music]
now
I saw something
[Music]
I felt it
[Music]
darkness falls across the land the
midnight hour is close at hand creatures
crawl in search of blood that contingent
error resolved neighborhood never shall
be found damned and ate the hounds of
hell
and the rock inside of Colton Michelle
whatever's happening it's spreading from
50 places
[Applause]
every woman
[Music]
justice please genius
[Laughter]
what did you do this weekend Donna me
nothing very interesting the world
remains in mourning after the death of
the Superman speculator no Spectre those
mechanics animal and where is the Gotham
back the math with Delaney has been a
no-show
they said the Age of Heroes could never
come again
[Music]
we don't have anymore time
[Music]
now protect issues
[Music]
no language
[Music]
look at Tommy
[Music]
it's really for
like obvious one this is the days where
mums biggest concerns were exploding
windup penguins this is crazy
mostly I think Roland died
each of us in some way is held back
don't engage alone people live together
it's really cool you guys ready to do
battle
relax Alfred I'll take it from here uh
do I know you
Superman was a beacon to the world
women just bathe people see the best
parts of themselves
oh I reckon that works well
we all have to recognize them
you have statement
[Music]
how many of you are there not enough do
you really think different oh wow they
just they really just vanish
oh that's rude
[Music]
you said you'd come now let's hope
you're not too late so much has happened
since I saw you I lost my hammer like
yesterday so that's cool pretty fresh
and then I went on a journey of
self-discovery my view
[Music]
well you have no idea
hello the goddess attached isn't paid it
as God oh I miss this
and you and I are fighters me
[Music]
now I want easily sound right Oh
[Music]
as god is dead little be reborn in - I
thought you'd be glad feeling you
discover here now to prevent Ragnarok
the end of everything
so I'm putting together a team
like the old days
surprise it'll be such fun
right
being a fighter
here we go
I'm not a queen or a monster
and goddess of death
what were you the god of again
[Music]
we're saying unite just a couple of
hotheaded fools
yes saying all quite fire door like
water I can't cuz I hire a whole like
raging fire - I like smoldering fire the
thing about war is it only works as both
sides believe they're the good guys the
truth is we're not so different
we fight to get back what was once ours
but in the end and this is the end it's
just a city you'll get used to watching
them fall like we're safe for now we
need to figure out our next vote well
it's not Mexico and there is no we
what is that we're not here to eat those
pork no I'm a shrimp oh this guy's got
pork god you're weird
I'm not looking for Super Friends
[Music]
I doesn't matter can't fight these
people not even with whatever it is your
hand can do it's cheap it's not their
hunting off friends or family and I'm
not going to stop there
[Music]
more dresses
the only thing keeping Manhattan from
Kremlin to a pile of dust the four of
you the wars are New York it's over
[Music]
I fear their forms
I can see you formed a kind of bond I
promise he was temporary
- they will disappoint you jo-jo like it
or not
people out there together
glad we found each other I'm not hugging
you stay long week
[Music]
[Music]
why is there fairing the birthday area
that's a new Norfolk very lives don't
matter today like their I'll take a
little homie out LAPD cell like you do
oh and now you keep doing all your
gangster stuff I'm just trying to sell
my house don't worry about that
everybody's just trying to get along and
have a good life all of the races are
different just because they're different
doesn't mean anybody's better or worse
than anybody
hey yeah where's the diversity on I got
a dude in my car I didn't ask for it
like the whole world is watching
but it's okay you don't like me
well I'm not here to be your friend I
need to know that you got my back can't
hide avoid units have physical tells
like the face what's my friends redoing
it needs a lot more carnival of country
do not wink at me like that
oh and like you stream on we have non
show us in route certainly wait for the
cavalry
we are the cavalry
what is it
magic
like a new killer weapon that grants
wishes that's whatever you want more me
taller or shorter you want ten million
dollars
we must feeling it was
and they
get out of this neighborhood
me killing you tell me and that's when
the stupid [ __ ] gonna start magic want
to secure it
[Music]
already knowing nobody built East out of
the Academy no they do not
you better keep coming
very sure
I can't get out of my hand
[Music]
that's the start
[Music]
we might be the promise we're not in a
prophecy we're going to goal in Toyota
Corolla
you
[Music]
looking for you what are we what if I
told you there's a place where people
have powers like us city of Adeline and
I can take you there
we're Inhumans maybe I'm foolish maybe
I'm blind and cannot see through this
bus behind brother sooner or later the
humans are going to find us got no way
to prove it so maybe I'm not the first
course of action will be to try to
destroy one I'm only human
wrong we need to go to Hearst now we
need to strike first it would only lead
to war are you speaking for yourself or
for our King
[Music]
Maximus is trying to take over aniline
are you going to kill your only brother
I'm only after honor me imagine you came
after all don't put the blame on me
never don't put your blame on me you're
just a human
[Music]
what is a gator a Jaeger is botanical a
human invention when the monsters came
we did not wait for heroes to fall from
the sky and save us we saved ourselves
innovation is ours to the pound
what a big economy it's you times a
thousand tall as a mountain
with a breathing hoarsely Burns's bright
[Music]
enabling us to become the most heroic
version of ourselves
join the Yaga uprising
[Music]
now
you